Democrats are raising the bar for the
next presidential debates if candidates
want to appear on stage next month
they'll need to prove higher poll
numbers and more donors and at any time
during this election cycle only 7 of the
15 candidates qualified to be at this
week's faceoff in Los Angeles the 7th
presidential debate is scheduled for
January 14th in Des Moines just weeks
before the first voters in the country
caucus in Iowa while the candidates are
looking to unite the party behind them
it may prove especially difficult due in
part to some big divisions based on age
the problem is highlighted in an article
in the Atlantic titled the Millennials
versus boomers fight divides the
Democratic Party and we're joined by its
author Atlantic staff writer Derek
Thompson Derek good morning good morning
so many places to go here but let's just
start with the frontrunners in the
Democratic Party and you think of a Joe
Biden and a Bernie Sanders and Bernie
has all this young support what are we
learning from just that alone the age
gap in the Democratic Party might be the
most important story in the Democratic
primary race of 2020 you draw a line
down the age of 40 and there's a real
interesting story to tell because
Americans under 40 seem to have
absolutely no interest the Democratic
frontrunner of Joe Biden and Americans
over 40 seem to have very little
interest in the favorite candidate of
younger Americans Bernie Sanders who is
arguably running in second place in this
party and I think it comes down to two
things I think it comes down to this
generation being really hit in the face
by the Great Recession the Great
Recession really took a toll on the
Millennial and Gen Z generation and it
has pushed them to the left and then I
think they've so much socialized on
social media talking to each other
commiserating learning to talk about the
problems of this country through a
different language the language of
democratic socialism not traditional
American Catholics like a third party
yeah yeah it's like we can make a
difference versus let's be the other guy
that is exactly what I think that is
exactly what I think because you know
traditionally in the United States
historically they're just been to
parties right we're not like England
we're not like a lot of countries across
Europe that have all these different
parties competing in a parliamentary
elect a system we just have to the
Democrats and Republicans but if you
look at the Preferences of younger
Americans you look at their preferences
not only for Bernie's
but also for policies like Medicare for
all for free college for student debt
Forgiveness extraordinarily popular
policies among Americans under 40 but
among Americans under over 40 they say
this is socialism we don't want it so
age divides not just Democrats and
Republicans but it divides young
Democrats from both Republicans and
their own it's not it's not just the
candidates it's the current leadership
as you point out in the article Speaker
Pelosi was born in 1940 Majority Leader
McConnell in 1942 President Trump in
1946 yes we have the oldest Congress in
American history we have the oldest
president in American history and in
fact no matter what happens in 2020
we're going to be setting a record
because you look at the top four
candidates its Biden it's Bernie it's
Warren it's pee poo to judge either we
will elect the oldest president-elect in
American history or we will elect the
youngest with people to judge it's
really a fascinating split you see
within this party well here's a quote
from your article the medicare-for-all
debate is a microcosm of a larger divide
can you expand on that yeah so Medicare
for all if you pull it is really
exquisitely sensitive to phrasing so if
you say do you want Medicare for all a
lot of Americans will say yeah that
sounds pretty good I like Medicare I
like for all it sounds great but if you
ask them about details that exist within
Bernie Sanders plan it starts to get a
little bit complicated if you say do you
support eliminating private insurance or
taxing all Americans a little bit higher
to pay for this plan it becomes
extremely unpopular and then again I
think just goes to show Americans over
40 like capitalism if you ask them
explicitly do you like capitalism or
socialism they say a big by about a
two-to-one margin we prefer capitalism
if you ask Americans under 40 it's
practically tied and among the Democrats
under 40 the edge goes to socialism so I
think it's very important to think about
this younger group not just as younger
Democrats but as a third party domiciled
within the Democratic real quickly
though Derek before we go this younger
party there are more numbers that are
older when it comes to voting at this
point but is there any indication that
these younger voters will come back to
the party instead of what they're just
their beliefs are will they stay with
the Democratic Party when it comes
election time if it's not their
candidate on the one hand a lot of
evidence seems to suggest that people
get more conservative as they get older
but peep
views on politics tend to consolidate in
their 20s so we may be living with this
for quite a while there agains the peace
with a great line not in a mean way but
at some point they have to grow up yes
yes literally a bitterly anxious well
how about that Derek Thompson he nailed
it
thank you so much
you